some things have been happening that
might be related
cold shower falling off my roof
And my heels
are on the ground
if you are loving this new live-action
Barbie girl in her Movie World here are
five more picks that are totally dolls
figuratively
now after years of speculation and
Wishful girls who turned into adults the
live-action Barbie movie is finally here
and honestly it seems like the weight
was worth it as this film has brought a
little something for everyone lovers
haters and all those in between
why because we're a girl with my
boyfriend you do what
I'm actually not sure so while you wait
to see if Dad back home is able to find
your old Barbies in the Attic or maybe
that's just my dad here are five more
flicks like this that are totally worth
unboxing starting with our brand new
pick Joyride just like Barbie this film
Blends a very strong female cast with an
adventure to a new place but it's a hard
R so it's just for adult Barbie fans
with stars like Stephanie Shu and Ashley
Park leading the way Joyride actually
revolves around four unlikely friends
who end up on a wild International
Adventure that not only bonds them but
teaches them a few things along the way
this movie is the directorial debut for
Adele Lim who previously co-wrote the
certified fresh films crazy Rich Asians
and Raya and The Last Dragon so she
knows what's up is what I'm saying now
critics are enjoying this ride so far
with a certified fresh 92 on the Tomato
Meter at the time of this recording and
that's thanks to reviews like this from
Top critic Valerie complex of deadline
Hollywood who gave props to the writers
for quote knowing when to have fun and
knowing when to get serious something
that I still haven't learned myself now
at 90 minutes long Joyride is just a
quick date to the theaters or eventually
an easy Friday night at home that you
can actually stay awake for and not be
on your phone for a Grand Adventure to
find your birth mother who needs more
parents when I have the two best parents
in the world
our certified fresh pick this week is
2007's Enchanted I love this movie this
self-parody from Disney Stars Amy Adams
as a singing and dancing princess to be
and it uses live action CGI and
traditional animation to pay homage to
various animated Classics so in other
words this one basically ticks The
Nostalgia box for you Barbie fans now of
course helping tie it all together for
enchanted was composer and genius Alan
Menken who actually worked on this after
previously doing the songs for some of
those aforementioned Classics like
Beauty and the Beast and Little Mermaid
I mean the dude's a genius now as you
might have guessed considering its
status as our certified fresh pick this
one is certified fresh at 93 on the
Tomato Meter the consensus from critics
Praises Adams obviously while calling
this quote a smart reimagining of fairy
tale tropes and you can actually stream
this hour and 48 minute gem on Disney
plus after that you'll have to decide if
you also want to watch the sequel
disenchanted which is rotten on the
Tomato Meter but I say go for it yolo
Giselle
[Music]
oh
bringing an always welcome 90s entry to
this list is our throwback pick 1998's
Pleasantville with similar themes to
Barbie centered around things not being
as perfect as they seem this film stars
Reese Witherspoon and Toby Maguire as
two siblings who were trapped in a 1950s
TV show I mean this plot is incredible
now despite being 25 years old this
comedy still has what would be
considered a stellar cast today with
recent Toby Maguire starring plus Jeff
Daniels Bill Macy Don Knotts and Paul
Walker in supporting roles I mean Paul
Walker in the 90s yes whether it was the
cast or the skills of the writer
director Gary Ross who also wrote big by
the way or both critics had Pleasant
reactions to this one pun intended now
the overall consensus calls it quote an
Artful blend of subversive satire and
well-executed Hollywood formula now
despite being a critical success
Pleasantville didn't do well at the box
office but if you can spare the two
hours and a few bucks to rent this one
maybe just maybe everyone's gonna be
okay what are you doing to these people
you can't do to them you're messing with
their whole universe
maybe it needs to be messed with David
keeping it in the late 90s were our
audience picked this week is the film
drop dead gorgeous now this is a
mockumentary and it centers around an
annual beauty pageant in a small
Minnesota town which gets majorly
competitive and then flat out chaotic as
bizarre incidents occur now it's led by
a great
1999-esque cast that includes Kirsten
Dunst Denise Richards as top pageant
contenders and Ellen Barkin and Percy
alley as their issue plagued moms and
drop dead gorgeous has an impressive 75
audience score with many of the over 50
000 reviews calling it one thing
hilarious it didn't really perform as
well with critics though who claim quote
it's dark humor sometimes hits but
mostly misses the target which kind of
sounds like one-liners on my dating apps
I try all you need is a subscription to
Max in about an hour and 40 minutes to
watch this one she wanted to see my room
and film me for their movie they ask you
to take your top off get the money for
first and finally our actor Spotlight
pick is Birds of Prey featuring Barbie
star Margot Robbie now this film marked
the eighth installment in the dceu
serving as both a spin-off and a sequel
to 2016's Suicide Squad and it was
thanks to Margot whose Harley Quinn is
the centerpiece of the movie for getting
this film made after she actually
pitched the idea to Warner Brothers in
2015 as an R-rated girl gang film now
this movie which is also known as Birds
of Prey and the fantabulous emancipation
of one Harley Quinn I love the title it
not only featured the first Asian woman
to direct a superhero film in Kathy Yan
but the result is a certified fresh hit
on the Tomato Meter and the consensus
from critics says that it quote captures
the colorfully anarchic spirit of Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn you can watch this
movie on Max in under two hours which
you'll soon realize is it near enough
time to watch Robbie do her thing as
Harley because she's great also there's
an incredible egg sandwich in this movie
that's gonna make you so hungry what a
way to start my new life
with the perfect egg sandwich well my
friends there it is five great picks to
fill up your Barbie Corvette so go party
be sure to let us know what you're
currently streaming in the comments and
check back here for more recommendations
based on the movies and shows that you
love right here on Rotten Tomatoes is
more like this I'm Nas Perez and I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]
thank you